the full transcript of former FBI
director Jim Comey's interview with
George Stephanopoulos has been released
it's a massive interview clocking in and
more than five hours and it's deeply
revealing by now you've probably heard a
lot about what coming has had to say
about Donald Trump and not very much of
that was newsworthy it turned out the
real value of this interview is what it
says about James Comey by the end you
realize that Comey never should have
been FBI director he's too partisan
Trump's main mistake was in not firing
him on inauguration day in his interview
with ABC Comey defends his prosecution
of Martha Stewart who you remember went
to jail for lying to federal prosecutors
he then attacks General David Petraeus
according to Comey Petraeus should have
faced far more than a lone charge for
mishandling classified information he
should have gone to prison for lying in
commis words lying quote strikes at the
heart of our rule of law in this country
fair enough the powerful should be held
accountable for their misdeeds but then
Comey goes on to talk about the Marc
Rich case to remember that on his way
out of office Bill Clinton sold a
presidential pardon to a wanted felon
who had fled the country Comey is
unambiguous about that case quote I've
never heard of another case where a
fugitive from justice was pardoned so
Stephanopoulos then asks the obvious
question quote did you draw any
conclusions about the Clintons about
Hillary Clinton from those experiences
commis response no none at all selling a
presidential pardon to a fugitive says
nothing whatsoever about the Clintons or
their character and by the way Comey
goes on to say that Hillary Clinton is
awfully smart and hard-working
Loretta Lynch gets the same soft
treatment Comey concedes that his
Attorney General when she did in fact
pressure him to describe the Hillary
email investigation as a quote matter
rather than what it actually was a
criminal investigation
dico me spot this obvious effort to
politicize justice nope not even close
his first concern when she told him to
refer to the Clinton email controversy
as a matter
than an investigation did you think she
was doing that to protect Hillary
Clinton I didn't know it worried me gave
me an uncomfortable feeling because the
Clinton campaign had been trying to come
up with other words to describe it you
know I don't know sis Jim Comey come he
doesn't know if Lynch was trying to
protect Hillary Clinton he doesn't want
to draw any conclusions from that he has
no idea if the Attorney General was
behaving politically when she told him
to parrot the Clinton campaigns talking
points coming goes on to say Loretta
Lynch is a very smart and good person
whom he respects very much we remember
in the middle of all of this saga
President Obama publicly and repeatedly
dismissed the entire Hillary Clinton
email investigation as a nothing burger
of course Hillary did nothing wrong
Obama said well Comey concedes that
Obama is a very smart lawyer and he
should have known better than to weigh
in on an active investigation as
president president shouldn't do that
quote do you think Obama was trying to
color the case Stephanopoulos asked once
again come he replies quote I don't know
I don't think so well there's a theme
here again and again partisan Democrats
get every benefit of every doubt from
Jim Comey he can't rush to conclusions
that isn't say sees the white circles on
her Donald Trump's eyes then he's happy
to speculate Comey says repeatedly that
lying is what bothers him most he's
devoted his life to fighting against
dishonesty that's why he wrote the book
he says but Comey also says that former
Director of National Intelligence James
clapper is the public servant he admires
most that's right the very same James
clapper who lied to Congress falsely
claiming that intelligence agencies
don't spy on Americans when he knew
perfectly well that they do does the NSA
collect any type of data at all on
millions or hundreds of millions of
Americans
no sir it does not not wittingly not
wittingly what she just saw is perjury
it's a federal crime
but unlike Martha Stewart James clapper
got away with that Jim Comey is happy
that he did the most revealing moments
the interview come when Comey describes
the alleged Russian plot against our
democracy Comey claims repeatedly that
Russia wanted Trump to beat Hillary
Clinton in the election but if it's that
simple why did Russian propagandists
apparently attack Trump as well and
staged protests against him Comey
doesn't address that instead he acts as
if we know for certain that Putin was
working on Trump's behalf but we
absolutely do not know that for certain
in many cases the facts contradict that
conclusion Comey is passing off
speculation as fact if Co being the FBI
really wanted to get to the bottom of a
Russian plot against our democracy why
didn't the bureau examine the DNC
servers to make certain that Russia
really hacked them to this day
regardless of what you hear we've never
seen any evidence that the government of
Russia
directed the theft of data from those
servers or from John Podesta Gmail
account from that matter we just take
that on faith everyone repeats it like
it's true but why should we believe that
without actual proof because people like
Jim Comey say so because our Intel
agencies never lie to us right companies
main piece of evidence that the
president is a Russian stooge is that he
never heard Trump criticized Vladimir
Putin even in private conversations I
don't know what's behind that Comey says
meaningfully the implication is that
Trump is unpatriotic a traitor to
America so that's the new standard
unless she denounced Putin vigorously
and behind closed doors our top law
enforcement officials suspect you of
disloyalty and criminal intent and then
all but accuse you of that on television
there's a name for this it's called
McCarthyism and it's scarier than
anything from has ever done with Russia
finally for a guy who says he's
determined not to be political Comey
seems highly political he says
repeatedly the interview with ABC that
he's greatly influenced by his wife he
cites a number of occasions when she's
weighed in on his job at DOJ
during the investigation into torture at
Abu Ghraib come he says again and again
that he listens carefully to his wife
well given that it's significant that
commis wife turns out to be a bitter
hillary partisan watch on Saturday
January 21st masses of demonstrators
take to the streets among them the
family of James comer my wife and girls
marched in the women's March the day
after president Trump's inauguration at
least my four daughters probably all
five of my kids wanted Hillary Clinton
to be the first woman president I know
my amazing spouse did I wanted a woman
president really badly you know I
supported Hillary Clinton a lot of my
friends worked for her and it's
devastated when she lost well wait a
second we have news here Jim Comey was
the director of the FBI working for
President Donald Trump a bunch of his
wife's friends worked on Hillary
Clinton's campaign virtually his entire
family marched against his boss on
Trump's very first day of work
Comey gave ABC photographs of all of
them carrying anti Trump signs on the
National Mall we're not supposed to
think that any of this had any effect on
how Jim Comey approached his job in the
Trump administration but of course it
did